I know that you have a passion for cars
and a lot of people would think okay a
guy comes into some money he's gonna go
out he's gonna get the Lamborghini the
Bugatti but that's not the way you went
that's not it's not the way you went and
have a picture here of the car you
bought and it is a 94 this is not a joke
it's a 94 Buick Roadmaster tell me why
the Buick Roadmaster unlike that fake
impossible turkey that's real yeah that
is real um I listen that that is the
high-water mark for station wagons in
American history 94 to 96 Roadmaster
posi track stainless steel dual exhaust
lt1 motor in front I took that out I put
a LSA supercharged I'm making 700
horsepower you put 700 horsepower 700
horsepower say miles to the gallon well
don't do that yeah it runs on rainforest
wood
put another tree wait a minute this
thing and and and this thing you put a
v8 in it and you're just any v8 a
massive powerful v8 what what could it
do what can this baby do on the highway
well we're looking at zero to 60 in four
seconds
you got a have if you've got two young
kids cuz you want to get out of that car
as quick as possible so the faster your
home the happier everyone is here's a
NASCAR it's a woodgrain station wagon
NASCAR you know what I love it's the old
wolf in sheep's clothing that it is like
you and I are sexual proud
here's the thing that I identify with my
family that I come from this big family
six
you know Irish family six kids and might
we always had a big station wagon so we
had a lot of them we had the rear-facing
yes that's what we had was we had the
rear-facing station wagon so and we also
I think my parents had a Roadmaster for
a while so but when I was growing up
they would always I would always get
relegated to the back sure in the end
they would flip up those seats and you'd
sit and you would look you're one inch
from the bumper by the way yeah yeah in
the event of a rear-end II yeah you're
gone yeah you put the kids who like
lease
my parents are always like Conan and
Neil get in the back and the children
who show promise will be in protected in
the middle but they would put us in the
back and we would sit and we would look
out the directly at the people behind
you yeah thank you it's so awkward for
them I put my kids back there too
because I can't hear them as loudly and
when they're in the way back and we'll
pop to a stoplight and then they're
looking out the window at the person
behind them and they're and then they're
like you know everyone's nice enough to
do it once so they're like and then the
light's still red and then that they
feel awkward so then they look like this
but then like might want to turn green
that is it and they're still waving so
numbers like no and then then when the
electrons relays get away from me they
want nothing to do with it I swear to
God the only reason I have a TV show and
have had one for 26 years as I spent the
formative years of my life looking
through a piece of glass at some people
that look board behind me being like hey
[Applause]
yeah well there's certainly practicing
they have that same captive audience and
we can only hope that they have their
own show yeah that is the goal between
frozen to and those kids having their
own show I'm in a hammock bless this
mess let me just ask you quickly do they
get upset that you're supposed to be
promoting bless this mess you get a
booking on this show you come on you
don't mention it
right and you talk exclusively about
frozen - well it's a really good movie
it really needs the help yeah and also
will be the the 1994 Roadmaster yeah it
needs something I'm sure I gotta put
some other part on it but um I don't
think they care cuz ABC's owned by
Disney so it's all the same thing right
I'm like a guy at Bed Bath and Beyond I
don't care if you buy the washer or the
bath mat it's all Bed Bath & Beyond
money I like you were like is that a
good analogy or about what am i a
analogy gender of the analogy police he
made acceptable I often run analogies by
you via email you know yeah texting me
and sending me stuff inappropriate